[Music]
i'm incredibly sorry for the distress as
it's caused to those young people
but it's still the right thing to do to
make the changes that we made yesterday
widowhood
is an excruciating journey
but what i don't want to do is spend
each day just
you know sitting trying to to get
through it i want to make
a change trigonometry and algebra that i
learned at school i don't use
very often i must admit but i do
use the skills of observation and to see
beauty
in things
[Music]
getting into university has never been
more complicated
despite now having the grades they need
these students are among thousands
who've found they still
can't go where they wanted hi i'm toby
newton from
hillingdon in west london and i missed a
place at cure university to study
medicine
hi i'm lauren from northampton and i
missed out a place to study veterinary
sciences
and i missed out on a place to study
medicine at the university of manchester
hi i'm nicole denmark from derby and i
missed out on a place at the university
of birmingham to study biochemistry
the u-turn on grades came too late for
toby
at that point key would fill their
places for medicine
so regardless of what i got i wouldn't
have been able to go to kill
anyway he's now going to his second
choice but the others are still in limbo
because of the delay all my places have
been given away so i'm stuck with
no confirmation of any place at the
moment i was devastated
because i'd already seen on track
obviously that my place for medicine
hadn't been confirmed luckily i did
have my insurance choice um that had
been confirmed
but i wasn't willing to give up without
a fight
it's just really frustrating knowing
that you know i put
months into deciding which one to put as
my firm insurance and that's sort of
just been
taken away from me and i might not
actually have the choice at the end
despite having the grades so we've got
courses closing all the time so we're
just adding them to the list to keep the
hotline staff completely informed about
what they can and what they can't offer
at call centers like this one at
birmingham city university there are
difficult conversations being had
is this your actual grade so that's your
actual brain okay
that's fine and then the psychology is
your actual grade as well
working really hard though telling
students that actually have now got the
grades that
they can't come on the course yeah it's
really difficult because
for them it feels like you know all hope
is gone and
they don't really know what to do some
students who'd accepted insurance offers
before the government newton
now want to change to their first choice
inevitably
some students will lose out how much of
a nightmare
is this for universities now it's
certainly very challenging
it's not a situation that any of us ever
wanted to be in with a show of hands who
feels
cheated by this process
like so many of their generation their
hopes have been dashed
their options for the future now limited
through no fault of their own
you're an education secretary who has
presided over the biggest fiasco in the
history of
a levels who's caused untold mental
anguish
to tens of thousands of students again
from the most
some of them from the most deprived
backgrounds you knew about this
for months and you didn't do it i'm just
wondering why you haven't done the
honorable thing and resigned
so when you say that you raised the
issuers to the fact that there were
concerns and people legitimately had
concerns that children from most
disadvantaged backgrounds
could potentially be disadvantaged by
standardization system
that was exactly our concerns as well
and if you look at the data it quite
clearly shows that the actions that we
took
made a real difference in terms of
actually ensuring that those children
weren't going to be disadvantaged as i
said yesterday i'm incredibly sorry for
the fact that this has caused distress
but the right thing to do was when it
was clear
that there wasn't the system wasn't
delivering what we believed it and been
assured that it would do
and the fairness that we all expected to
deliver
and we all had confidence and belief
that it would deliver
then further action had to be taken
that's what i
that's what i did that's the decision
that we took and that's what we did
yesterday
[Music]
the widow of pc andrew harper who died
when he was dragged by a car
while trying to stop three men is
calling for tougher sentences
for people who kill emergency service
workers the three men were convicted of
manslaughter
and sentenced to between 13 and 16 years
last month
but earlier i spoke to lissy harper who
said life in prison
should be the minimum sentence for
anyone convicted of killing
a police officer firefighter doctor
prison officer
or paramedic the past year has been
awful and i think all we've been
focusing on all i've been focusing on is
the fact that he's not here
but coming up to the end of the trial it
was clear that you know something needed
to change here
and you know the least i feel like the
least we could do
is offer protectors some protection
did andrew always want to become a
police officer
you know anyone who knew him you could
see that that was
suited to him he was always very
protective
and kind proactive
and he always wanted to help people he's
always had a very strong sense of right
and wrong
um and i think you know all of his
friends we all
knew that he was so suited to that role
i mean i was just so proud of the way
that he
he did his job and he was just so
dedicated to it
widowhood is an excruciating
journey but what i don't want to do is
spend each day
just you know sitting trying to to get
through it i want to make
a change and i want to do something like
you say that
he would be proud of the pain will
always be there for me
the journey will always be hard
but i do constantly feel lucky to have
had
the relationship that we did you know
it's a long time even for
for any relationship let alone one that
was
stolen so abruptly
so it's hard but you know he he keeps me
going
and he keeps me focused on what's
important and
you know that's why we're doing harper's
law i think
are there are there happy times that you
can still dwell on now
when you you know you remember your life
together many many happy times yeah
um you know we were together for over 12
years
um so that's a huge chunk of our
lives that we were side by side um
you know every memory i have is it you
know
attached to him in some way so
you know i'm just glad we took so many
pictures
you called his death barbaric um so how
shocked were you then
at the verdict that the the three young
men
were found not guilty of murder my
husband has been taken
and the people responsible will not be
paying for that
there is no escaping the agony in beirut
hospitals already inundated with victims
of the explosion
are now filling with protesters injured
by the security forces
firas hamden told me he was out on the
streets last saturday
and whilst filming this facebook live
was almost killed
you can see the explosion in the center
of the crowd
a metal pellet from what it's thought
was a grenade pierced his heart
i walked for two meters and i
shut down as i collapsed on the earth
and
the other colleague that i will bring
to him i am glad to be
alive it pierced all the chest walls the
heart from side to side and it launched
into the posterior
posterior wall of the heart firas
underwent emergency surgery
and amazingly he'll make a full recovery
dr kareem neme who's been treating him
says he's seen more than 50 patients
wounded in the protests
many of the injuries are too graphic to
show
all the injuries were on the upper upper
part of the body
face shots neck shots chest injuries
all all of these could kill
the patients could kill the protesters
lebanon's anti-government protests
erupted after the explosion at the port
the human rights activists and doctors
claim the methods deployed here by the
security services
are in breach of international law
[Music]
ravi barakat bears the scars from the
tear gas canister
it appeared to have been fired directly
at his face
he's come back to the place where it
happened to tell us
what he remembers i had no idea
whether this was live ammunition rubber
bullet
or a tear gas bomb i would really like
to
know who gave the order to shoot these
tear gas bombs straight
straight to our heads and i would really
like to
to look him in the eye
and tell him was this really necessary
human rights watch observed these
protests first
hand it's conducted its own
investigation
the evidence is overwhelming security
forces
seem to have fired live ammunition at
protesters they seem to have fired
rubber bullets including a protester's
faces which is prohibited by
international law
the lebanese authorities are denying
they used excessive force
or rubber bullets but in this country
hollowed out by years of corruption
where people have no faith in the
government it's a response that's
unlikely to be believed
[Applause]
on the airport tarmac a lifeless looking
alexei navalny is wheeled into a waiting
ambulance
his fellow passengers witnesses to a
horrible episode
which his campaign staff claim was a
deliberate poisoning
from the cup of tea he had in the
airport
these his groans as emergency staff made
their way through the plane
just before he lost consciousness in the
toilet he's now in a coma
and on a ventilator in the siberian city
of amsterdam
putin has hated navalny ever since
navalny has
sort of surfaced as a credible threat to
his power
but i think what what has provoked this
attack right now
is the situation in belarus in a
neighboring country
you have a similar type of dictatorship
uh lukashenko has been there for 26
years
and all of a sudden out of nowhere it
looks like the bella russian people
are going to kick lukashenko out and
putin is watching this
and this is a potentially very lethal
situation for russia because these types
of of attacks or
these types of revolutions jump borders
and he's looking at who's the most
likely person that would uh sort of step
in
to rally the people in russia and that's
lexi navalny and so
there is a motive which is which is um
this whole uh election of only being an
opposition guy there there is the
timing of the belarussian situation and
most importantly the russians use poison
on a regular basis
the russian government uses poison on a
regular basis against its enemies and
we've seen that here in the uk
with the skripals we've seen that um
with white fanianco
let's turn to tony brenton who served as
british ambassador to russia between
2004
and 2008. uh tony thanks very much for
joining us today we talked to mary
dejevsky yesterday
who said it was it was facile really
just assume rather lazily this is
unquestionable with the work of vladimir
putin she said he has
nothing to gain from it and that seems
to be your view in the paper today
that's absolutely right um i know him i
very much hope that he gets better
the world is instantly concluding of
course that putin is guilty that the
russian medics and the russian medical
profession is on the whole
an objective professional organization
particularly a hospital in norms which
simply wasn't ready for this have
sounded very professional in their
response to it they've done the checks
they've reached their conclusion
and i suspect that that conclusion is
accurate
[Music]
mass testing is the only way to prevent
an economically catastrophic
second national lockdown this winter
well that is the stark view of former
prime minister
tony blair who says the government must
act now to roll out a huge
increase in tests matt hancock the
health secretary was saying that the
government does not want to move in the
direction of mass testing and that's
to be welcomed but it's also urgent it's
because
the really two things i think we that
lie behind
the desire for mass testing number one
the majority of people who get covered
19
are asymptomatic so in other words they
they
suffer mild or no symptoms and therefore
if you're only testing the people with
symptoms
you're not capturing a large number of
people who despite being asymptomatic
can nonetheless spread the disease
so that's the first point and the second
point is that it's one thing
for the government to permit people to
do certain activities
but the question is how do you build the
confidence in the public that they
actually do those things
so you can say to people go back into
work but if they don't feel
safe then they're going to be reluctant
and if you want to reopen schools
universities workplaces if you want
international travel to function again
the only way i think you can do that is
by doing testing
at scale and that's why we've got to
move to this and
you know what we've tried to set out in
the paper which which i signed actually
not just myself but with william hague
who's my old conservative opponent and
jeremy hunt
is just to say look this is not a
political play it's just
when you look and and by the way when
you track what's happening around the
rest of the world
this is where people are moving they're
realizing that unless
you can get a handle on who's got the
disease
who's had the disease it's very hard to
get the economy functioning again as it
should
but you say that mass testing needs to
be set up now or in the month of
september to avoid a potential second
wave that could hit the uk in autumn i
mean we are running out of time aren't
we if that is the case
yeah we are running out of time and
that's why it's it's it's very urgent
now to be fair to the government it's
not that they've been doing nothing
i mean we've got the capacity now to
test about 340 000 people a day
but actually we're only using around
about 170 000 of that
capacity so we're only using about half
the testing capacity we have now
so one of the things we suggest is as
you build up
to mass testing using all the available
lab
facilities and these new rapid on the
spot tests
that we we also engage in using
the testing capacity we've already got
in order to to test more groups of
people
well now there are warnings that the
illegal use of drugs like
benzodiazepines such as xanax
and diazepam by young people is rising
the prescription drugs are usually used
to treat things like anxiety
but now there are a number of dangerous
fake illicit drugs being sold instead of
the painkillers
i'm joined by dj one man who used to be
addicted to xanax himself great to talk
to you dj one man
well tell us how you got caught up in it
how did you get addicted how long
were you addicted to it for i dunno um
so i first discovered the drug in
2012 um
and i was through a dj from chicago
called richard
um he was touring in the uk and i he
ended up passing away in 2014
um from a drug overdose which the
autopsy found xanax
along with heroin and cocaine in his
system i was using it to tour mainly to
sort of sleep on flights but it kind of
crept into my life for the next five
years
was it easy to get your hands on then
easy and relatively cheap
really easy really cheap when i was
buying them in 2012 they were
i think 10 quid for 15. these were real
as well these weren't fake ones
um the glorification through uh xanax
and benzos in rap music
from 2014 up to 2017 it's steve it was
steel eagle now has made it
sort of a drug of not of choice but
um of curiosity for a lot of kids in
this country
and tell us about the effects about mood
changes
just how did it how did it affect you
from stories or things that my friends
and family have said about me
or just yeah being a monster there was
one point apparently i went to a
restaurant with my mum dad and brother
and completely lost it was picking the
pasta up off of his plate with my hands
just total behavior you just wouldn't do
i i just wouldn't do
but the danger for me was when i was
drinking with it because
what a lot of people don't realize is
when you mix alcohol with these benzos
you have a blackout and
i've lost three friends to um zanax
addiction and they've all died in
blackouts where
you just forget how many you've taken
there was one time i had a
bag of 20 and i thought i'd taken three
i woke up the next day and there was
three left
like that's how dangerous the blackouts
can be so mixing with cocaine is
bad for the heart but with alcohol it
just you completely forget what you're
doing
oh goodness me so was it that was that
that experience you mentioned
three of your friends dying i'm
interested in in how you've got off it
how you how you've become
clean so my my parents and my
music manager in 20 um early 2017
um no sorry early 2016 they were like
this is enough
um they checked me into rehab um
they drove me down there and i was it
was probably the best thing
anyone could have done for me at that
point because i'd just gone through a
divorce
i didn't want to face the emotions and
the people around me
that i'd sort of let down i guess i felt
like it was a really dark time in my
life that
this drug i thought was helping me
through but
it ultimately only made things worse for
me and
everyone around me
while countless musicians would cite the
stones as being one of their biggest
influences
if you want a clue as to who inspires
ronnie wood look no further than his
paintings
from picasso to delacroix he's no
stranger to selling out stadiums
but in a matter of hours tickets for
wood's biggest art exhibition to date
were gone
taking place in the grand setting of
ashridge house
the stone's guitarist can't wait for
people to see what he gets up to
off stage there's an incredible amount
of noise going on in those paintings
anyone that gets into the painting and
observes close enough can hear the din
that's actually coming out of it
it's fair to say wood knows a thing or
two about filling life with
colour of course decades of hard living
and hedonism from being in one of the
biggest rock bands in the world will
probably do that but what many people
don't know is that the painting
actually came before his performing
trigonometry and
algebra that i learned at school i don't
use very often
i must admit but i do use the skills of
observation
and to see beauty in things i was
painting before i learned how to play
the drums and the guitar do you
encourage your little ones to sort of
slosh paint around
yeah i do yeah yeah they make an awful
mess as well
during lockdown as well as spending time
with the newest additions to his family
wood has spent most of his pandemic
painting
producing works like these i thought
i'm not going to let lockdown
depress me in any way sometimes i have a
musical
period or maybe it's just the art that's
what i've been doing lately is not
playing
and not through choice but you know
i'm looking forward to the day when i
can play again
[Music]
of course at the moment it isn't
entirely clear when the stones will be
able to be back doing what they do best
we're not holding our breath otherwise
we will collapse
the thing is there's got to be a time
when
somebody sorts out what we you know some
direction what we're going to do
somebody's got to lead this thing
are you assuming at the moment it is
going to be a few years before you're
back out on tour
oh no please don't say a few years
i want to be out this time next year for
sure
content for now to show that there are
more than the six strings to his bow
but be in no doubt ronnie wood has no
plans to permanently swap
playing for painting re-energized he's
raring to get back on the road